uh go ahead and turn it over to
our treasurer zach conan who will talk
about the instrumental role the state
played in making sure that we received
um 30 million dollars for these relief
efforts
thank you councilwoman good morning
everyone i am your nevada state
treasurer zach conan
it's so nice to see so many friendly
faces uh on the line hello congresswoman
hello
commissioner i wish we were all together
in person but i know we will be there
soon
in the treasurer's office our focus
since beginning of the pandemic has been
on ensuring that the economic recovery
of the state
was as quick and effective as possible
to that end the governor signed
executive directive number eight at the
end of march and that put an eviction
and foreclosure moratorium in place that
was a great first step
but now we need to do the work to make
sure that nevadans can remain in their
homes
this rental assistance program is a very
big part of that
the cares housing assistance program or
chat is being run statewide
and we know that many families have been
hit hard by the economic impacts of
coven 19.
our goal was to stand up a program that
is easy to understand
easy to apply for and will ensure that
landlords get paid back as quickly as
possible
on monday this program launched
statewide
designed to help tenants with back rent
that is owed during the period covered
by that eviction moratorium
now in order to ensure that tenants
could receive assistance quickly and
effectively
we worked with clark county social
services the reno housing authority
and the rural housing authority to stand
up a program quickly
and effectively now we've seen an
incredible response since monday and i
want to thank commissioner naft
and tim burch who i see in that tiny
little window there for all their hard
work to get the program up and running
you know during these times your county
officials your state officials
your federal officials your city
officials are all working together
uh and in this case the county came up
with it first
and we were happy to be able to pile on
with some additional funds
so the state of nevada is providing 30
million dollars in short-term rental
assistance to nevadans experience
financial hardship due to covet 19.
that money comes out of the cares fund
specifically coronavirus relief fund
dollars
that were hard fought for and won by
congresswoman titus and the rest of the
federal delegation
now those state dollars that 30 million
dollars will be 20 million dollars to
clark county
10 million dollars to rural counties in
washoe
and that will go on top of an additional
30 million dollars that has already been
allocated by clark county so a total of
about
50 million dollars in clark county funds
will be paid directly to landlords on
the tenant's behalf
relief funds are offered as grants
they're not loans they do not need to be
paid back
um and in clark county funds are being
distributed through a network of 14
community non-profits that i believe
clark county will talk about in just a
second
so the fastest way to apply for funds in
clark county is for tenants to call one
of these non-profits directly
they'll be then notified of any protect
required documentation necessary
and they'll take you through the process
we've got plenty of information on
eligibility and the rest
all of that can be found either on clark
county's website or if you're not sure
where exactly to go
you can go to the housing.nv.gov page
that's the
state's central landing page and that
can direct you to wherever you need to
go based on
eligibility and the rest again thank you
so much for having us here this morning
really excited about this process and i
know it's one of a series of efforts
that the state
city county and our federal delegation
are working to put together
to keep nevadans in their homes and make
sure we get out of this crisis
as uh well as possible
thank you treasurer conan um for your
remarks and for your hard work
and making sure that nevada stays on
track during these very difficult times
um now with us we will have um
two gentlemen who have a great
responsibility
and and a great role in administering
these monies and making sure that
they're getting into the hands of
of our community members and we have
with us county commissioner mike naft
and clark county administrator tim burch
to speak
more about these dollars and programs
that are being serviced by clark county
good morning thank you councilwoman good
morning and thank you for ensuring that
we are doing a good job outreaching to
every community that needs the services
that we're providing
i also want to point out while we have
the important
uh and challenging job of distributing
these funds and putting a program
together that
uh safely securely and equitably
distributes these funds
we would not be in this position if it
weren't for congresswoman titus
for leadership uh leading the delegation
to fight for the dollars that we have
to spend today it is these are
terrible times but that safety net that
we now have in place and those dollars
that we're able to
immediately put to work are thanks to
the congresswoman
and her experience and hard work in
washington fighting to bring those
dollars back to
the small state of nevada i'm joined as
you mentioned with tim burch who's been
working for the last six weeks to
develop a program
that would do just that that would be
there in place for
the anticipated 120 to 150 000
nevadans many of whom are in clark
county who are going to need
this assistance in the coming weeks no
doubt about it
and what i want to make sure we're doing
too is reminding people that this is not
a time to be bashful
this is a time to stand up and accept
assistance if you
think that you and your family need it
we're anticipating having people
utilize programs that have never
utilized
safety nets like this before but that's
what
these dollars are here for and i know
that's uh what we want to
do to make sure that they're available
and to make sure that we're approachable
along with our 14 partners that
to work with us on the non-profit side
um
so i thank you for helping us spread the
word and
again i just reiterate to everybody in
clark county and throughout the state of
nevada if you
are in need of assistance whether it's
through these programs that we're
talking about
today utilities mortgage assistance or
rental assistance
or if you're a small business owner the
county has provided
millions of dollars to assist our small
businesses of under 20
employees who are in need today right
now if we can bridge that gap
during these difficult months uh that we
have ahead
it will be a so much cheaper and cost
effective aside from it being the right
thing to do to bridge that gap
and help people get through the other
side so thank you councilwoman uh thank
you trevor for partnering with us on
this
um and tim you want to add basically how
people can take advantage of these
programs that we have to offer
absolutely so uh at the department of
social services you know we're grateful
for the leadership at the federal state
local level inside our department uh
inside of the community
and we're able to work with 14 community
partners who have a history
of getting money into hands with people
who need it most
but this is an unprecedented amount to
address an unprecedented
economic crisis in our community so
again we built the program for
folks who don't traditionally come to
the department of social service and ask
for help
we're trying to make it easier for folks
to get that help as possible
so it's as easy as going to help
home.org
and if you don't have access to
broadband uh or internet access
in any way you can simply call nevada's
uh 2-1-1 system from any cell phone or
landline it's about 2-1-1
and ask for the help that you need and
get the list of the 14 non-profits
one of them hope link is on with us
today to get the assistance unique
uh we scaled this program to be able to
work for families who were traditionally
two family working incomes with
those behind the rent maybe for the
first time in their lives and they don't
know how to ask for help so once again
just go to helpfulphone.org
apply directly with any one of the 14
non-profit partners
we're working to get this money out to
individuals through
and again we just look forward to
continue working with the state federal
and local leadership
as this crisis continues
thank you so much commissioner naft um
all the best to you and your lovely
daughter
and uh thank you mr burch for all the
hard work that your
department is doing during these uh
unprecedented times
really appreciate it now with us
to kind of walk us through what it looks
like from the non-profit
side and and how folks will have
i lost them jay it froze
but maybe it'll come back i know i can
hear you let's see what's going to
happen
i think it's just the council when we
lost oh greed
okay well i think she was going to um
she was going to turn it over to me so
you can all still hear hear me yeah yes
okay perfect that'll work then
um it is a pleasure to be here and
i want to um echo the other sentiments
i i really want to thank everybody for
all the hard work they've done
and for listening to our non-profits
when we asked that you know the money
come as fast as possible
that it be as flexible as possible
and that it not just be for one or two
months
but into the end of the year at the
minimum
we at hopelink really wanted to position
ourselves
so we weren't just here in july or
august but we would be here
remember in december to help people as
well
as we all know um there are people that
have gone back to work
but there's many people who haven't yet
and may not have jobs to go back to so
this
is this is really an our eye is going to
go on for quite a while
and and past the end of the year we
really expect we will be
um you know helping people next year
that are still being affected by this
um hopelink our mission is
number one to prevent homelessness and
to preserve families and provide
hope if we can help somebody stay
in their home when they're on the brink
of homelessness from one or another
crisis
that actually does help solve our
homelessness problem
we don't want to see our homeless
population increase
so these monies being able to pay back
rent as far back as
march bring people you know
up to current keep them whole
as well as provide food
from our food pantry keep meals on
tables and provide utility assistance to
keep the lights and the air conditioning
on as well
we're doing everything we can to take
care of
the things that are the largest expenses
in a household
and the most vital to somebody remaining
stable
um since march we've never shut our
doors
um some of our crew went remote but we
always had
staff in the office we've answered our
phones every day we've answered emails
every day
and our numbers have consistently
gone up more than doubled month to month
to month
um last month we served over 1932
clients
over 600 of them were children between
the ages
of 5 and 17 and then about 400
um adults between the age of 24 and 35
it really represents those households
those families out there that are really
in need of assistance
we do have a lot of people coming to us
who have never
asked for assistance before and really
had to
um you know kind of ramp up their
courage
in in order to come and do it um and
we're just so glad that we're there to
be able to help them
we've been spending on the average um
before this money came through
about 50 to 70 000 a week helping to
keep our
neighbors and our community members
stable
since launching the program this week we
converted our conference room
into a covet response center we've hired
four temporary
uh case managers so far in order to kick
the program
off uh we're fielding about a thousand
phone calls and emails every day
and in two days this week we cut 263
checks for emergency shelter rent
and utility assistance so
it has
the word is out but we want to make sure
that we continue to get it out and we
spread it further
so those who haven't heard about the
assistance yet who hear about it and are
able to
go to 2-1-1 go to our website united
way's website all the different
resources out there
to see who does have relief
unfortunately i know that all the
nonprofits
due to the uh call volume some people do
have a little trouble getting right
through we ask them to be patient and to
just continue to call
for us the best time to call us first
thing in the morning
we have the capacity to do about 50 full
appointments every day
and that is the screening the process on
all the ways
cutting the chat um as as we see if
the response can uh we will look at
adding
more caseworkers to help
with that need and the volume of calls
coming in so
i have uh leticia
guerrero from our office is also on the
call
unless we lost oh there you are you're
up in the corner um
leticia is one of our caseworkers
um she is also the one
that um when i receive a spanish
speaking call
i often refer them to her she's
wonderful about working with our
hispanic and latino community members
a lot of times as we know there is that
language barrier they may not have the
technology at home
um so she really walks them through the
process helps them with the application
and what documents together that we need
in order to process and approve
the financial assistance so i just um
want to turn it over to her for a minute
or two so she can sort of walk you
through the process
that she goes through from the time she
receives a phone call from someone
latissa you'll have to unmute
hi good morning can everyone hear me
yeah okay so basically the
process is um they would have to call
the main number
um once they call the main number in the
afternoon a case manager will return the
call
and we get their email and we will email
them a link
and all they have to do is create an
account once they create the account
they will be able to complete the
application and upload their
documents we try to make it as easy as
possible for them to go ahead and do it
as
up to this point everyone has had an
email
or we can email all the information um
some people are not
very tech savvy so we'll work with them
if um
most of the time they have a friend they
have a relative that will be able to
help
if they don't we always have other other
options they can come to the office we
can give them
give them a paper copy where they can go
ahead and fill it out and
we'll um turn in their their documents
we'll make the copies for them
i mean we try to reassure that once they
call we'll
make sure um that they complete the the
process to
to get the assistance so that's that's
the main
process yeah and let
is
is
leticia i've had a request are you able
to
um bring your camera back up there you
go
thank you
so at time if we can wait to the end
and any questions that you have for
myself or leticia
we will be happy to stay and answer
um so um councilwoman i will turn it
back over to you
congresswoman titus we will move right
over
and um turn it over to you and again
thank you from the bottom of our heart
for all of your hard work
so we could help the community well
thank you so much and thank you for
having me today
you know we all know that if the economy
is hit
nationally las vegas takes it even worse
because people have to have money in
their pocket
to be able to go on holiday and so much
of our economy
is based on that hospitality industry
but we do also know that las vegas is a
resilient city we've been hit hard
before
and we always come back stronger than
ever and i think that's what will happen
this time
and one of the reasons is because we're
all working together and because of
programs like this that y'all have done
such a good job of
setting up and now getting the word out
so i want to thank our treasurer for
taking the lead here but i must say we
need to get back out there because that
beard's getting kind of long zach
i don't know uh olivia our councilwoman
for
bringing us all together even though it
is virtually
and certainly our commissioner mike matt
your leadership during these difficult
times has just been
amazing and the examples all have set
have really uh made a difference in las
vegas that we haven't seen
among leadership in some communities
around the country
uh and working with the non-profits like
hope link is just great because
now it's gonna take all of us everybody
in government working with the private
sector and with the non-profits
to get out of this you know my district
is the heart of the valley and this is
where so many
people are tied to the hospitality
industry and so many
uh really need the assistance that y'all
provide
they are struggling because they don't
have a job just to keep a roof over
their heads so these kinds of programs
are really great i was pleased to
uh support and work for and
and vote for the cares act that set up
this first
amount of funding to go to these types
of rental assistance
programs they they've done a good job
y'all are out there we're going to share
your information on our website any way
we can
you'll just have to let us know how best
to do that and
also we get about a hundred calls a day
from people needing assistance so now we
have a great place to refer them
if it relates to any kind of housing but
despite all your hard work and the
amount of money sounds good when you
just throw a figure out there
we still need to do more the house
democrats
passed the second version of cares which
was known as the heroes act
and that included additional funding for
uh
housing in fact it was a trillion
dollars would go to state and local
governments to make up for lost revenue
and then you had a hundred billion
dollars for rental assistance
and another 75 billion dollars for
homeowners assistance in addition to
that we looked at the eviction problem
and extended the moratorium on evictions
for one year
and foreclosures for a different
additional six
months has been out there passed by the
house and those deadlines are coming up
very quickly unemployment's about to end
the eviction protection's about to end
people are about to hit a wall
that's not necessary if we could do
something to get the senate to move
we're working on a compromise it took
them until yesterday to come out with
their plan
unfortunately their plan does not
include money for state and local
governments
does not include money for uh any kind
of homeowner assistance it does
provide an increase in the amount you
can deduct for three martini lunches
however that's not what most of the
people in my district
and then the parts of the district that
we all share are really
looking for so we're we will begin to
work now
on the compromise we will be here next
week and then break for august
hopefully something can come by the
first of august
uh so that people will not hit that wall
uh because you know we if we take a step
back then it will take us longer be more
expensive and be even
harder to recover so i just can't thank
you enough for what y'all are all doing
on the ground
on the front lines to be sure that this
funding
gets to the people who really need it so
thank you for that
and thank you for having me today
thank you so much congresswoman titus i
apologize i'm having technical
technical difficulties on my end um my
laptop started stopped
getting a signal and i had to switch to
my cell phone so
um please do know that i would have
loved to have introduced you as part of
the press conference but i had a
technical glitch
um i understand i am low-tech i'd much
rather be seeing you
in person than on zoom but we have young
people around us here who helped me to
get it done so
i'm just glad that you're here and thank
you for inviting me thank you for your
leadership
and continuing to communities in dc and
we know we need more resources to help
us here
on the ground and we're so grateful for
you advocating for us in d.c
um
with that i'll turn it over to the press
for any questions you may have for any
of the participants
yes good morning i'm luz greg with the
nevada independent and espanol
i have a couple of questions uh well
thank you for this
press conference by the way i would like
to know
how many applications clark county has
had so far
yeah so tim burt have account for you
just yet
we are asking the providers to give us a
count at the end of each week
in regards to the number of applications
number of families actually
served and the number of founders in the
queue so we'll
provide that data through our cio office
to you all
on uh early next week
councilwoman lo siento i i've got to go
and vote
uh but if anybody has any questions i
can come back later thank you so much
for including me i'll see you later
okay this one is uh now
i have other question um
how has the color experience has been so
far like
have people been reporting long haul
times
you know in in regards to hope link um
we try not to put people on hold
um we're answering the phone as quick as
we can
we have a special recorded message um
should they not get through right away
that that you know let them know the
volume is is high
and to call back but we also um
reference our website and the other
agencies that
have funding available as well you know
it's it's
it's our hope that if they can't get
um on the appointment list for us um say
today
that we can provide the resources of the
other organizations in town
so they can go ahead and try and call
them as well we
want people to get relief as quick as
possible
so we're referring to each other
thank you
all right but i don't know if other
members of the president
go ahead louis and ask your questions
and we'll see if anybody else has them
thank you um based on early demand will
clark county
consider putting more cares act funding
toward
this program
well i think right now thanks to uh
trevor conan and the governor and the
state's assistants we're at 50 million
dollars in clark
county so we want to the program's just
getting started we i think we all know
that the need is great
uh and the monies
well um so but i think until we get a
little further into the program
um not more money is necessary though as
congresswoman titus mentioned
uh certainly the need is there so if the
federal government's able to provide
additional funding
fentanyl mortgage utility assistance
we've got
what i think will be one of the best
programs in the country
for distributing those funds
thank you
well i'll ask the next question what
does the county say to create
critics uh who say this doesn't help
people who have tried their hardest
to make their rent payments during the
endemic but are struggling
well i think that's partially who it's
geared towards uh so certainly that's
who we want to help so i would
i guess i would tell them to call my
office and we could talk about why they
think they're
not being served but certainly that's
our aim and the goal and objectives
to help individuals
i'm sorry the audio is not really uh
clear could you please repeat
the answer thank you very much i i just
said the the individual that you're
describing in your question is exactly
who we're trying to help
so if anybody uh feels like they're
being left out of the
uh that's being offered i'd encourage
them to call us
and discuss that um and we can always
look at reevaluating programs to help
more people whenever possible but
i think through this program it's fairly
comprehensive
with the rent mortgage utilities
um so i i think a lot of people will be
helped
um as tim mentioned people who don't
often
utilize clark county's social services
who by the way are
pandemic or not clark county social
services are always here
and always working with these 14
non-profits and many others
throughout the year to help people these
are thanks to these cares act dollars
additional funds that we're able to
supplement
and support even more people who need
assistance down more than ever
records
is
hi my name is alexander zapat i work
with young uh
i have a question for consumption woman
olivia diaz if you can answer in spanish
okay
[Music]
so the question is how are we ensuring
that our northern nevadans also have
access to funds
um to make up you know the arrears and
rent
and utilities i'm not very familiar with
the structure
up north so could you speak to what's
being done there and then i can
say it in spanish absolutely
councilwoman
so up north uh we're working with the
regional housing authorities so that's
the reno housing authority for washoe
county
and the nevada rural housing authority
in uh the rest
of the rural counties they both have
access to an initial tranche of five
million dollars so 10 million
uh and they've received a few hundred
applications in the rurals and about a
thousand applications in reno so far to
date
uh that process is online uh but the
mechanics meant
uh match all of the processes down here
in clark county
so just for my education and
accuracy treasurer conan how will
someone in northern nevada then
um right here we've advocated call 211
go to hope
uh help home let me get this right
help hope home um
on the web so what would someone in
northern nevada do
to be connected to the housing
authorities
step one is go to the housing
department's website that's
housing.nv.gov
they can also call either the reno
housing authority or the rural housing
authority
um and i can certainly share those
numbers with the press separately if
need be
okay do you know that there's bilingual
staff on board with them yes
there are yeah okay good
one last question zach how many funds
are available to people in northern
nevada we talked about 50 million here
in southern nevada how much is
available to our northern residents
we're starting with five million dollars
in our rural communities and five
million dollars in washoe
but of course the need just like it is
in clark is going to be greater than the
funds available right now so we'll
continue working to get
new funds into the system um to build on
something that
commissioner naf said earlier we're
going to have a really great program
here so when additional federal funds
come in
we'll have a mechanic to quickly get
those funds out which i think will put
us ahead of the game
[Music]
um
but i just want to make sure i don't
misspeak tim
if you could help me how many months in
arrears do folks have to be
in order to qualify for this uh rental
slash mortgage relief uh
thank you councilwoman the uh applicants
can simply be behind on their current
rent they don't have to be months and
months behind
we will go back all the way till march
first
but if someone's just now getting behind
or they
will be behind i'll say their august
rent coming up because
they haven't gotten called back and the
extended unemployment runs out
um they can then get an assistant apply
as soon as they're passed due
and we'll start working with that
landlord as hopefully stated so well
this is an effort to make sure people
stay stably housed and the program
will run until the money runs out or up
until
december 30th which is the deadline for
the use of the federal funds
is
familia seguras
thank you
any other questions
doesn't sound like it so i i from the
bottom of my heart i want to thank
uh hope link for doing the yeoman's work
and being in the trenches and providing
this much needed assistance to our
community which is gracias hopefully
established
thank you secretary secretary
thank you treasurer conan for all of
your help
uh in in getting these funds channeled
to our entire state not just southern
nevada but
our entire state our i know all of our
community is in dire need
commissioner naft and mr burch thank you
again
for participating this morning and
ensuring that our community is informed
about how to access these funds and
to be patient and persistent but that
we're trying to get the
the much in their hands and
congresswoman titus thank you so much
also i know you had to drop
off but we appreciate you continuing to
fight for us
and did i leave anybody off my list i
think
i said thank you to everyone and thank
you to the press thank you for
carrying our message into our community
to make sure that everybody's informed
about this opportunity we really
appreciate you